[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'il fout flavien à la veille
média ce qui a été en retard désolé
c'est quand même dingue quoi chaque fois
qu'on fait un truc avec lui il est
toujours en retard c'est sûr je reste
dans la voiture oui messier là je suis
sûr que tu restes dans la voiture j'ai
juste pas envie que quelqu'un te
reconnais c'est tout j'ai envie depuis
ce single ces derniers y avait alors un
ristretto pour estrada n'est impossible
pour prise
moi je me suis pris un petit lac et au
caramel bon et aubrystes j'ai trouvé que
ça tu vois très sérieux pour les -
dacquois j'ai passé quand même plus
pratique pour se repérer non courants
quoi faire un braquage
ah ouais et donc toi tu peux nous au
café à côté de la banque
ça dérange pas tant jamais contents bon
il est où je viens parce que je les prix
ont-ils été mais c'est quand même
meilleur show bon écoute et on va faire
une pause sur flavien parce que ça
commence à me rendre dingue je me pas
pourquoi on l'a prise à cet abruti puis
peut-être parce que c'est lui qui a eu
l'idée
[Musique]
flavien sait ce qu'il dit j'arrive dans
10minutes besoin de quelque chose à de
l'huile et la [ __ ] animations [ __ ] on
a oublié les masques et sur nos baisers
j'ai tout prévu toi et moi du coup j'ai
pris des politiciens je suis que ça fait
plus original à temps il a fait de la
politique francis lalanne non mais
attendez malentendu moi je fais pas de
braquage
ma tête nomel je suis parti sur l'udc
c'est qui ça sert collègues s'étaient
dégagés fait le dégager ça m'a pris ce
format jean-luc très bon jour et ça te
manquer le boulot du côté revenus oui
ouais et ckoi remarque genre à fait
pareil à ta place à non mais attends
c'est dégueulasse qui t'ont fait laïque
ont viré après dix ans toi tu trimes tu
trimes en plus avec ton mari au chômage
et égaux c'est tout c'est dégueulasse
en plus je crois qu'il prévoit d'autres
licenciements dans la nuit à bout moi je
sais pas comment tu fais pour rester
aussi ça moi moi moi même on a fait ça
moi je pourrais faire dit des trucs
takoucht pense qu'à pas cool c'est à
dire je ne sais pas j'ai pas l'idée la
maintenance est là mais je pense que ou
là attention tu as a way au francis own
way francis lalanne ah oui c'est mon
idée c'est moi qui ai le mal qu'on se
dit l'amour maladie les grains d'un
trimaran que l'on sait les portes qui
claquent les j'en ai ma claque c'est du
cinéma à quand on fait m
fais moi l'amour l'amour frère et moi
l'amour
ou pas la guerre je vais pas faire
l'amour je rigole si tu me regardes ça
ma voix la matrice est moi j'y vais un
réunion 8h46 kasraoui allez salut qui
nous avait foutu des comptes ou quoi
c'est pour ça qu'on a acheté des masques
faut y aller là parce que les convoyeurs
de son vont pas tarder à arriver donc
façon je crois qu'on va faire comme dans
la fois pour les vacances on va partir
certains ont même eu un problème du coût
qui va s'occuper des coffres et moi moi
je peux le faire je perdrais pas c'est
tout je connais tous par coeur je
pourrais vidé les coffres mes yeux
fermés donc moi ça m'a trois clics à
droite puis 2e à gauche
[Musique]
bonjour excusez moi falloir dégager ce
qu'on va bientôt intervenir mais oui bah
a pas de souci qu'est ce qui se passe en
fait un problème
ouattara qui a pris la banque en montage
et on peut savoir ce qui a fait le coup
parce que moi je travaillais là en fait
je crois un certain jean luc je crois il
vient de se faire virer la pète un câble
et vous vous faites quoi ici
rien n'empêche la barre on va commencer
à la touquet et sinon vous auriez point
un petit café en plus par hasard
non là on a tout lu je sais ce que je
vois c'est pour ça je demande
non mais il est un peu tienne on
ressasse c'est pas grave c'est au fond
je suis non mais c'est pas de la du
bonbon café con c'est vrai tenez
[Musique]
c'est un robuste ah bah ça m'a fait du
bien voyez ça va mieux et drôle de
journée comme ça allez circulez voir
[Musique]
bon bah allez-y vous parce que moi de
façon une coupure à moi j'ai jamais fait
ça de ma vie moi vous parlez là dedans
l'appui vous appuyez bon
j'allais à la guerre ça pas la guerre
mais c'est ma chanson alors allez-y
[Rires]
merci à tous d'avoir regardé ce skate
j'espère qu'il vous a plu et si vous
voulez voir d'autres sketch de même type
vous pouvez pas venir vous balader
tranquillement sur notre chaîne qui
s'appelle amaury quand on est bon on en
entend pas de pub pas de pub sur la
chine doit changer c'est pas bien mais
c'était juste une petite habitation
comme ça découle non mais voilà si vous
voulez vraiment vous abonner à notre
chaîne fils abonné qui étaient abonnées
direct